quel genre de personne aimeriez-vous
voir en tant que président des États-Unis eh bien,
j'aimerais voir quelqu'un qui a le
courage de commencer à tenir tête aux
propriétaires de ce pays
[Musique]
répondre à la question sénateur je suis
chrétien je  comprenez que vous êtes
chrétien, je n'ai pas beaucoup de temps et
j'apprécie que si vous répondez aux
questions, vous n'obtiendrez pas mon vote,
je ne sais pas
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
[Musique] le
socialisme signifie fondamentalement que la démocratie
est une société dans laquelle vous n'avez pas une
poignée de banques et de sociétés géantes
contrôlant la vie économique et politique
de la nation
[Musique]
c'est si quelqu'un vous dit que la politique c'est de
la merde c'est  les ordures ne s'impliquent pas ne
les croyez pas un instant les
décisions prises chaque jour dans
la capitale nationale ou le gouvernement de votre ville
sont d'une importance énorme pour
votre vie et si vous ne participez pas,
d'autres personnes combleront ce vide
[Musique  ]
non seulement je me battrai pour protéger les
familles de travailleurs de ce pays, mais nous
allons construire un mouvement de
millions d'Américains qui sont prêts
à se lever et à riposter
[Musique]
ce n'est pas que Donald Trump a remporté les
élections, c'était  que le
Parti démocrate a perdu les élections Donald Trump l'un
des grands scientifiques de notre temps
[Musique]
ma question est et je ne veux pas être
grossier mais pensez-vous que si vous n'étiez pas
multimilliardaire vous seriez assis
ici aujourd'hui  ne pensez-vous pas que c'est une
bonne chose, eh bien, je pense que ce qui serait
mieux, c'est que vous disiez tout de suite
que vous reconnaissez que nous avons une crise mondiale
[Musique]
Je me présente à la présidence parce qu'une
grande nation est jugée  pas par le nombre de
milliardaires et d'armes nucléaires dont il dispose,
mais par la façon dont il traite les plus vulnérables